privatisations immédiates de tf1
engagement d'un processus de
transformation de fr3 en scène deux
chaînes de référence selon monsieur
léotard la taxe sur les magnétoscopes
sera supprimé suppression de
l'autorisation administrative pour les
licenciements économiques le projet de
loi du gouvernement adopté en conseil
des ministres françois mitterrand
exprime ses portes aux réserves et sa
désapprobation
michael gorbatchev à la télévision
soviétique ce soir et volent sur mobile
7 morts 299 blessés mikhaïl gorbatchev
propose une rencontre à ronald reagan en
europe ou à hiroshima
icahn 39e festival bernard rapp avec
franco zeffirelli aujourd'hui 14 mai
1986 les otages français détenus au
liban
marcel carton marcel fontaine michel
seurat jean paul kauffmann et l'équipe
d'antenne de philippe rochot georges
hansen aurel cornéa jean louis normandin
et camille sontag n'ont toujours pas été
libérés
antenne 2 est à l'honneur pour le prix
albert londres qui récompense chaque
année des journalistes de grand portage
a été décerné à philippe rochot pour la
qualité de ses reportages réalisés
l'année dernière au mozambique et au
liban les jurés du prix albert londres
ont associé à philippe rochot georges en
scène aurel cornéa jean louis normandin
retenu avec lui au liban mais aussi
jean-jacques le garrec reporter
cameraman qui a accompagné philippe
rochot au mozambique et au liban le jury
a également rendu hommage à jean paul
kauffmann
bonsoir c'est dit ce sera tf1 cet après
midi le ministre de la commune de la
culture et de la communication françois
léotard a saisi l'occasion des questions
d'actualité à l'assemblée nationale pour
annoncer la privatisation de la plus
ancienne des chaînes de la télévision
française tf1 voici en quels termes la
privatisation
est en effet un élément essentiel si
l'on veut éloigner l'états de
l'information réduire l'importance du
secteur public et favoriser sans trop
tarder l'existence d'un secteur privé de
qualité c'est-à-dire de création en
plein milieu entre haineux qui est celle
à celles des trois chaînes publiques qui
a contribué de la manière la plus
consistante à la création demeurera la
chaîne de référence du secteur public
tf1 sera privatisée l'importance de son
audience lui permettra de faire face à
la concurrence tout en supportant un
niveau d'obligation de contribution à la
création au moins égal au niveau actuel
pour fr3 le gouvernement a entrepris une
étude approfondie des divers aspects de
l'activité de cette société et des
différentes possibilités d'évolution du
statut de cette société avant de voir en
détail le projet de monsieur les auteurs
et les questions qu'il soulève ainsi que
les réactions politiques avec
jean-michel mercure lesjak aubertin
comment au siège de tf1 rue cognacq-jay
le personnel de la première chaîne un
petit peu moins de 1500 personnes et
environ 300 journalistes pour l'ensemble
des journaux aux magazines a pris
connaissance de son futur sort avec la
privatisation immédiate d'une chaîne du
secteur public
il s'agit de tf1 et l'engagement d'un
processus de transformation
alem s'il annonce de la privatisation
était dans l'air c'est tout de même avec
inquiétude que la rédaction de tf1
apprend la nouvelle officiellement
aparté dans les couloirs plutôt que
déclarations au micro qui s'étendent
déjà beaucoup de monde en tout cas pour
la conférence de rédaction où le journal
du soir se prépare dans une ambiance
apparemment détendue mais aussi
soucieuse de l'avenir
nous avions pensé que le meilleur moyen
de s'organiser dans ce nouveau décor
serait la constitution d'une société des
journalistes de tf1
très vite circule l'idée d'une assemblée
générale des personnels ce ne sont pas
les syndicats qui l'appelle mais tout le
monde se retrouvera dans un studio pour
apprendre la candidature au rachat de
robert hersant monsieur vers saint déjà
bouclé son tour de table avec des
partenaires financiers et souhaite est
opérateur de la future chaîne privée
nous sommes pour une grève immédiate si
nous ne le faisons pas nous allons être
manipulés et nous allons être balayé et
puis on marche de l'agitation il ya
aussi ceux qui accueillent la nouvelle
avec philosophie
j'avais j'ai 22 ans de maison j'ai vu
beaucoup de remous au sein de la rtf de
lower tf de tf1 une antenne 2 messieurs
j étais dans le même temps je crois que
j'ai pas lieu de s'inquiéter il faut
d'abord savoir si j'ose dire à quelle
sauce on va être mangé le président
directeur général de tf1 monsieur hervé
bourges a diffusé cet après midi une
déclaration j'en prends un extrait je
prends acte des intentions du
gouvernement concernant la privatisation
de tf1 c'est un choix symbolique aux
conséquences multiples et monsieur
bouffe conclut je veillerai
personnellement à ce que les intérêts
professionnels matériels et moraux de
ses personnels soient respectées selon
françois léotard le système français
fondaient sur des monopoles de diffusion
et de création paraissait à bout de
souffle et ayant du mal à faire face à
la concurrence technologiques et
culturels étrangères le projet du
ministre est connu dans ses grandes
lignes restent une série de questions
concrètes que vous vous posez sans doute
vous téléspectateurs
analyse de gaming à tout seigneur tout
honneur c'est à la fois la chaîne la
plus ancienne la plus regardée et celles
qui emploient le plus de personnel qui
est donc privatiser la première tf1 a un
budget de 2 milliards et demi et un
déficit chronique depuis de nombreuses
années passées au privé les programmes
devraient continuer à faire la part
belle à la création ce sera inscrit dans
le cahier des charges
elle sera financée par la publicité
uniquement il y a déjà des candidats au
rachat puisque dès cet après midi robert
est recensé déclaré preneur mais il
pourrait y en avoir bientôt antenne 2
devient donc ce sont les mots du
ministre la référence la chaîne publique
avec les obligations du service public
ces obligations qui pourraient être
allégées
le pdg sera nommé par la nouvelle
commission de la communication antenne 2
devrait conserver ses ressources
publicitaires pendant trois ans mais
ensuite fonctionner avec la seule
redevance fr3 devrait être privatisée
en séparant peut-être fr3 nationale du
réseau régional mais tout cela est à
l'étude et pourrait prendre du temps le
temps de regarder comment cela se passe
pour la une
allez vous continuer à payer la même
redevance pour deux chaînes au lieu de
trois on n'en sait rien elle pourrait
être diminuée et surtout ce n'est qu'une
hypothèse
fiscaliser pour en faciliter le
recouvrement en revanche c'est sur la
taxe sur les magnétoscopes est supprimé
enfin une nouvelle commission de la
communication aux pouvoirs très étendus
sera chargé d'étudier les conditions de
la privatisation de fixer le prix mais
aussi des garanties culturelle elle aura
tout pouvoir sur le nouveau paysage
audiovisuel français
le projet de loi sur l'audiovisuel
devrait passer en conseil des ministres
à la fin du mois les syndicats ont réagi
très rapidement à cette annonce de la
privatisation de tf1
un préavis de grève avait été déposé il
ya plusieurs jours par la cfdt la cgt
rejoints par le snj syndicat national
des journalistes
la cftc qui n'appelle pas comme il faut
la grève à la grève a demandé à
rencontrer le ministre françois léotard
à l'assemblée nationale où les propos du
ministre ont été chahutées patricia
charnelet a recueilli les opinions des
députés de la majorité et de
l'opposition
nous combattrons cette mesure je pense
que nous ne serons pas les seuls c'est
un mouvement très vaste qui
on peut peut-être se rassembler autour
de la défense du service public et il
est peut-être possible de faire reculer
ce gouvernement je crois qu'ils ne
mesurent pas bien
les déséquilibres qu'ils feu instauré
dans l'ensemble du système audio
division audiovisuel français notamment
du point de vue de la création et du
point de vue aussi de l'originalité
notre culture qui tout se passera dans
la transparence et sur ce point nous
avons ce qu'il faut pas faire ce qu'il
ne faut pas faire c'est ce qui a été
fait dans les années qui ont précédé ou
dans les mois qui ont précédé notamment
pour la chaîne 5 et pour la chaîne 6 la
privatisation de tf1 se passera dans des
conditions de transparence et de clarté
absolue
tf1 appartient non pas au gouvernement
non pas un parti non pas un groupe privé
mais où français eux mêmes
vous savez je crois que beaucoup de gens
en france nous n'accepterons pas que
leur bien commun leur patrimoine commun
qui est en même temps celui des artistes
des créateurs des techniciens des
journalistes qui pendant 40 ans ont
fabriqué une bonne télévision
peu de personnes accepteront ce bradage
un intérêt paix qu'elle roule
l'attribuez-vous à la seule chaîne du
service public reste ans
bien qu'elle le fasse dans l'objectivité
son travail vous êtes des journalistes
vous n'êtes pas des porte parole mais
encore faut-il que lorsque vous émettez
un certain nombre de jugements et l'eau
ce qui vous arrive de mettre en cause
des personnalités politiques
donnez leur la possibilité de répondre
monsieur jean drucker président
directeur général d'antenne de déclarer
aujourd'hui à cannes où il se trouve
actuellement qu'il était très flatté
quand tranchant dans ce sens le
gouvernement et considérés quand n2
pouvait constituer la norme de référence
pour le service public et monsieur
drucker a souhaité que sa chaîne puisse
disposer de tous les moyens nécessaires
à la réussite de son exaltante mais
difficile mission suite des réactions
c'est tout d'abord de président de la
haute autorité madame michèle cotta
elle a rappelé que la haute autorité
dans sa majorité s'étaient toujours
prononcée pour un équilibre et une
compétition entre les secteurs public et
privé et à la ajouté que tout ce qui
peut pénaliser cette équipe fragile
notamment l'existence d'une seule chaîne
publique me paraît à titre personnel a
dit mme cotta dangereux pour la
production française
réaction d'un autrement de la haute
autorité le communiste daniel karlin
c'est une politique folle et suicidaire
enfin réaction de l'ancien ministre de
la communication monsieur georges
fillioud les téléspectateurs ont tout à
perdre
dès la fin de l'après midi le groupe
hersant confirmait qu'il était candidat
au rachat de tf1 il n'est pas le seul il
ya aussi le groupe achète alors que la
marche c'est un petit peu la surprise on
s'attendait à nous antenne 2 peut-être
une autre mais certainement pas tf1 un
premier temps c'est vrai la déclaration
de françois léotard cet après midi a mis
fin à un long suspense digne d'une
grande série télévisée et les pilotes
comme dans un bon téléfilm n'est pas
celui qu'on attendait on nous avait
d'abord annoncé la privatisation
d'antenne 2 c'était le voeu du ministre
puis celle de fr3 c'était le souhait de
matignon résultat c'est tf1 qui est
choisi mais ce choix ne relève pas d'un
tirage au sort il obéit à une logique
précise la vente d'antenne 2 aurait
assuré à son assez heureux acheteurs un
succès immédiat l'image de la chaîne est
bonne et sa gestion rigoureuse antenne 2
gagnent de l'argent
les nouveaux propriétaires n'auraient
donc eu aucun effort à faire si c'est en
quelque sorte un cadeau tf1 en revanche
est en déficit
même si elle a une bonne audience le ou
les groupes qui veulent s'installer rue
cognacq-jay devront donc faire leurs
preuves c'est à dire concilier le profit
et la qualité voilà l'argument avancé
par le gouvernement qui a finalement
opté pour cette solution c'est une sorte
de pari que fait monsieur la hauteur pas
seulement pour lui c'est en fait un défi
pour tout le monde pour les trois
acteurs qui vont jouer désormais un rôle
important
premier acteur vous avez raison le
gouvernement en privatisant tf1 notre
aîné il le convaincre les français que
la recette libéral leur permettra
d'avoir une meilleure télévision
mais si les syndicats se révoltent si
les grèves se multiplient
si les téléspectateurs sont privés
d'image le gouvernement ne risque-t-il
pas de subir la mésaventure que les
socialistes ont subi eux mêmes sur
l'école
deuxième acteur les candidats au rachat
ils ont tous un point commun ils sont
riches ils ont donc la possibilité de
s'offrir tf
mais l'argent ne suffit pas forcément à
faire une bonne télévision
il faudra du métier de l'imagination
mais aussi des scrupules résisteront-ils
par exemple à la tentation de courir
après l'audience au détriment de la
qualité
troisième acteur enfin antennes de la
chaîne de service public face aux autres
privés ou privatisées rude concurrence
aura-t-elle les mêmes moyens financiers
en un mot autant d'argent
surtout si elle est privé de recettes
publicitaires dans quelques années
aura-t-elle la même liberté de manoeuvre
que les autres chaînes devra-t-elle être
enfin la chaîne officielle
la réponse du gouvernement à ses
questions se veut rassurante antenne 2
sera nous dit on la chaîne de référence
bel hommage à nous maintenant de relever
le défi est de faire rimer référence
avec concurrence et indépendance
l'assemblée nationale une motion de
censure a été déposé aujourd'hui par les
députés communistes prennent la décision
du gouvernement d'utiliser l'article 49
3 c'est-à-dire vote bloqué mettant fin
au débat le vote sur cette motion aura
lieu vendredi
la hausse des prix pour le mois d'avril
0,3 ou 0,4 pour cent selon l'insee qui
publiait aujourd'hui son estimation au
mois de mars les prix avaient augmenté
de 0 3% et en avril de 0 7%
le rythme annuel d'inflation se ralentit
et des banques baissent les taux des
livrets et les taux de base bancaire les
taux d'intérêt du livret d'epargne
devrait baisser demain 2 1 et demi pour
cent voilà pour la cour d'assises des
prix les lieux de 6 en avril 86 on
arrive à 0,3 ou 0,4 après cet indice des
prix jean revient donc aux taux
d'intérêt des livrets de départ qui
devrait baisser demain 2 1
et nuit pour cent et le taux de base
vainqueur d'un demi point et puis je
vous rappelle que le dernier délai pour
payer le tiers provisionnel c'est demain
à minuit au conseil des ministres
philippe seguin chargée des affaires
sociales et de l'emploi a présenté son
projet de loi sur la suppression de
l'autorisation administrative de
licenciement dans un premier temps
l'inspection du travail n'aura plus à
vérifier le bien fondé économique
les suppressions d'emplois l'explication
avec gérard leclerc
après le vote de la loi les inspecteurs
du travail n'auront plus leur mot à dire
sur le bien fondé économique d'un
licenciement
l'entreprise devra simplement respecter
les procédures conventionnelle c'est à
dire consulter les représentants du
personnel pour éviter un vide juridique
dans les petites entreprises où ces
procédures n'existe pas le texte prévoit
quand il y a moins de 10 licenciements
un entretien préalable entre l'employeur
et les salariés concernés
troisième point une entreprise qui a
licencié il y a moins d'un an pour un ré
embaucher sans autorisation de
l'administration
enfin les nouvelles mesures
d'accompagnement des licenciements
procédure délai plans sociaux seront
négociées entre syndicats et patronat
avant d'être reprise dans une loi à la
fin de l'année cette suppression de
l'autorisation administrative de
licenciement figurait dans le programme
électoral rpr udf s'appuyant sur des
exemples concrets comme celui de la
société trop nico installé à saint
philibert près de la roche sur yon en
vendée
jacques chirac l'avait évoqué reportage
quand une pertuis michel alik off je
suis pour la suppression de
l'autorisation préalable de licenciement
je vais vous donner pour conclure un
exemple
exemple que donne et jacques chirac ce
soir là celui d'une entreprise vendéenne
employant 113 personnes et travaillant
dans l'électro mécanique en février 83
le marché pétrolier s'effondrent les
commandes baisse de 70%
le chef d'entreprise doit licencier 25
personnes sont massées
bah sauver à tout prix une entreprise
sauver le maximum d'emplois par ici
puisque on a rompu tout le monde on
valide
passé par fable après quelques mois en
effet l'entreprise à de nouvelles
commandes elle peut réembaucher les
personnes licenciées mais seulement 22
sur 25 et à contrat à durée déterminée
le chef d'entreprise est condamné il
n'avait pas le droit d'agir ainsi dans
l'année qui suit à licenciement
il devait demander l'autorisation à
l'inspecteur du travail
aujourd'hui cette élection va sauter
produit saq com beaucoup d'employeurs se
réjouit et envisage d'autres solutions
pourquoi ceux commis aurait pas si vous
voulez après ces licenciements décidés
par l'entreprise à son personnel
pourquoi n'y aurait-il pas par la suite
commune et une commission dite
économique et si elle pouvait statuer
sur les mesures prises par l'entreprise
et son personnel et voir même notre
astre rétroactivement le tour on
retrouvait une condamnation du chef
d'entreprise pour être les centres et
aux médecins selon lui vivant c'est une
des possibilités qu examinons les
syndicats au cours de leurs négociations
avec le cnpf chez trop nico on craint
que cela ne fragilise la situation des
salariés
il y aura certainement beaucoup de
contrats à durée déterminée
l'emploi sera certainement beaucoup plus
précaire et
il aurait certainement beaucoup plus de
licenciements oui oui on fait aussi des
embauches embaucher si on lis entre plus
étonnantes disputé pendant bourse que
son contrat à durée déterminée les
embauches reste bien maigre finalement
le salar jean n'aura cerise aucun retour
le patron et le 4 août or accusé droit
le bateau il sera le 2 x fut maître à
bord rassuré par la loi les chaînes
entreprises embaucheront plus facilement
c'est sûr mais personne ne peut dire si
ce sont des emplois nombreux et durables
qui seront créés pour le ministre
philippe ce gars l'autorisation
administrative préalable de licenciement
telle qu'elle était conçue avec des
effets pervers sur l'emploi et ne
faisait que retarder des licenciements
pour monsieur seguin sa suppression
n'entraînera pas un accroissement du
chômage
je ne pense pas pour ma part que la
formule génisson point sera de nature à
d'abord à montréal jean l'arbitraire qui
a pas l'arbitraire puisqu'à les règles
et notre part qu'elle sera de nature à
encourager particulièrement les
entrepreneurs haïtiens
je ne m'attends pas à une vague de
licenciements liés à la promulgation de
la loi
jaurès le cas avec le sexe vague de
licenciements il serait relativement
brève puisque nous avons encore la
possibilité d'interdire par la loi et
que nous la besoin au cours du conseil
des ministres le président mitterrand a
exprimé ses fortes réserves et sa
désapprobation au projet de loi de
monsieur seguin
monsieur mitterrand a rappelé cependant
que l'initiative des lois appartient au
gouvernement
réaction de monsieur gattaz le président
du cnpf
je suis satisfait des mesures prises la
levée de cette contrainte va permettre
de créer de très nombreux emplois
les syndicats comme la cftc ont rappelé
leur désaccord et monsieur bergeron pour
force ouvrière tout en regrettant la
décision gouvernementale a souhaité que
le cnpf engage immédiatement des
négociations pour monsieur bergeron
l'effet montreront très vite que cela
n'améliorera pas l'emploi sur cette
question commentaire de gérard morin ce
projet de loi sur les licenciements plus
faciles ne va pas créer des emplois
selon la plupart des études trois
instituts de recherche économique ont
dit récemment que cette suppression de
l'autorisation administrative pour
licencier n'entraînerait une
amélioration de l'emploi qu'à partir de
1990 91
le sénat dans une étude à paraître
demain envisage trois millions cinq cent
mille chômeurs en france en 1991
à plus court terme l'institut de la
statistique prévoit rien que pour cette
année 86 160000 à 220 mille chômeurs de
plus seul le cnpf affirme que la loi
présenté aujourd'hui permettra de créer
trois cent soixante dix mille emplois
cette affirmation repose sur des
prévisions des chefs d'entreprise et le
ministre du travail veut bien croire
qu'ils feront le maximum pour embaucher
mais on le voit aujourd'hui il ya
davantage de craintes que d'espoirs pour
l'emploi pour justifier la loi présenté
aujourd'hui l'argument principal n'est
pas technique mais psychologique et
politique le gouvernement a donné des
gages pour que les entrepreneurs et
confiance mais un ministre important la
dite également aujourd'hui
maintenant la haute évident aux
entreprises de jouer
la fédération de l'éducation nationale
prévoit une campagne de mobilisation
pour la rentrée 86 la fn trouve la
politique gouvernementale je cite
inacceptable et catastrophique
communiqué du ministre de l'industrie
monsieur alain madelin
il y à une sorte de réduction de
constate une réduction des achats de
produits frais au marché d'intérêt
national de rungis et monsieur mais de
la communication jour aucun produit
d'origine animale ou végétale destinée à
la consommation humaine ou animale sur
le territoire français ou exportés par
la france ne présentent un quelconque
danger
cela est à relier avec la masse des
radioactives qui auraient survolé la
france à moscou que le numéro un
soviétique mikhaïl gorbatchev prenait la
parole ce soir à la télévision
déclarations de monsieur gorbatchev
après la catastrophe nucléaire de la
centrale de tchernobyl près de pierre
lescure bischoff a annoncé que
l'accident avait fait sept morts et 299
blessé des personnes qui souffrent
d'irradiation mais monsieur gorbatchev
n'a pas parlé que de cela j'ai
immédiatement après le générique du
journal télévisé soviétique il y à une
heure si new world of donc est apparue
en personne pour faire le bilan de
l'accident nucléaire de tchernobyl
celui là on vous l'avait dit neuf morts
299 blessés souffrent dit monsieur
gorbatchev d'irradiation crise ou moins
graves
nature monsieur dans match ne mâche pas
ses mots il parle d'emblée du malheur
qui frappe le peuple seul malheur mais à
voir la solennité son visage on comprend
qu'il s'agit plutôt d'une catastrophe et
tous les soviétiques qui n'était pas
encore pleinement sensibiliser à la
gravité du fait maintenant ce soir ils
doivent l'être
et puis après le bilan vient la
polémique
monsieur gorbatchev s'en prend au
gouvernement aux médias occidentaux qui
selon lui auraient exagéré la gravité de
l'accident dans un but politique et
polémique
et puis il passe de l'atome civil à
l'atome militaire qui reste le grand
danger à ses yeux alors là on attend une
proposition monsieur votre chauffe et
toujours des propositions dans ce
discours est la proposition vient il dit
que l'urss va proroger son moratoire son
arrêt unilatéral des explosions
nucléaires militaires jusqu'au 6 août
et ils proposent à nouveau à monsieur
régal de le rencontrer pour parler
justement de l'arrêt des essais
nucléaires militaires de le rencontrer
ou éventuellement à hiroshima a lors de
l'explosion de tchernobyl à l'explosion
d'hiroshima compenser les
téléspectateurs soviétiques de cet
enchaînement vraiment dramatique à
l'attaché militaire américain de
l'ambassade des états unis à moscou et
est expulsé les soviétiques lui
reprocher une importante action
d'espionnage la maison blanche à
washington a confirmé aujourd'hui que la
syrie s'efforçaient toujours d'obtenir
la libération d'otages occidentaux au
liban et s'est montrée prudente sur la
possible implication de damas dans le
terrorisme international
dans le souci apparent de ne pas
compromettre donc les efforts de la
syrie selon la chaîne de télévision
américaine cbs le président syrien
monsieur hafez el assad aurait engagé
personnellement des efforts intensifs
pour faire libérer les cinq américains
et les neuf français enlevés au liban à
zagreb en yougoslavie un tribunal a
condamné à mort le criminel de guerre
artu kovic andria article beach un homme
de 86 ans il avait été surnommé le
boucher des balkans
le voici il était accusé d'avoir fait
massacrer 500 personnes
et incendié plusieurs villages et
yougoslaves transfert sous bonne escorte
celle du gign du jeune tunisien habib ma
main celui ci avait avoué lundi dernier
à nancy être l'auteur de plusieurs
attentats en france et en
grande-bretagne contre les magasins
marks and spencer une banque et la
compagnie israélienne el al habib ben
ammar a été inculpé et écroué à la
prison de la santé
le pilote italien elio de angelis 28 ans
l'équipier le coéquipier de ricardo
patrese dans l'équipe brabham est dans
un état désespéré à l'hôpital de la
timone à marseille elio de angelis été
victime d'un accident ce matin sur le
circuit du castellet
il a perdu le contrôle de sa voiture les
causes de l'accident de ce pilote très
expérimenté au volant de la plus basse
de toutes les formules 1 reste
inexpliqué reportage larry bodiguel et
robert rosier à l'hôpital de la timone à
marseille
elio de angelis est toujours dans le
coma et le pronostic des médecins est ce
soir très réservé
ce matin peu après 11 heures le pilote
italien est violemment sorti de la piste
il souffre d'un traumatisme crânien de
lésions aux vertèbres cervicales et à la
colonne vertébrale ainsi que de brûlures
l'écurie brabham avait profité de la
proximité du circuit du castellet avec
monaco pour y effectuer une série
d'essais privés l'accident s'est produit
après le premier virage de la verrie une
courbe très ouvert qui saute moins font
largement au dessus de 250 km heure
la brabham donc d'elio de angelis
on suppose qu'ils avaient perdu son
aileron dans le deuxième virage déesse
de la verrerie c'est-à-dire aux
alentours du poste numéro 3 qui est ici
ensuite les parti en tête-à-queue ceci
c'est pascal ma très haute vitesse c'est
à dire au delà de 150 km heure
elle est partie en tête-à-queue elle est
restée calme sur la piste là elle a
décollé sur une vingtaine de mètres
ensuite allait retomber du côté droit de
la piste
elle a franchi le rail de sécurité la
[ __ ] en rail de sécurité elle a
redécollé à nouveau et elle est tombée
dans la voix de sécurité et où elle a
glissé sur environ une centaine de
mètres à l'intérieur de la voix de
sécurité est à l'arrêt la voiture a pris
feu au moment où les secours sont
arrivés la voiture était en flammes
et elle était retournée elio de angelis
étaient prisonniers sous sa voiture par
les médecins ont découvert il était en
état d'arrêt cardiaque
ils ont réussi à le réanimer et il a été
aussitôt transféré par hélicoptère à
l'hôpital de la timone où il a été admis
au service de réanimation des urgences
il y aura de la boxe demain à paris ce
sera la salle pierre de coubertin deux
championnats du monde au programme cette
exceptionnelle avec notamment celui ci
le mexicain julio cesar chavez est pas
lui c'est celui qui est en culottes
vertes
c'est un exceptionnel puncheur audio
cesar chavez il est 49 victoires dont 43
ans imite on voit ici à las vegas et
1,85
il a mis quatre fois au tapis son
concurrent wiseur l'américain avant de
réussir un ko à la deuxième reprise
c'est donc demain soir au stade pierre
de coubertin des titres et des lauriers
ce sera à cannes lundi prochain en
attendant le festival garde son soleil
et ses films en compétition bernard rapp
est en compagnie de franco zeffirelli
mais auparavant spielberg
le film de jure et bien c'est carter
paul la couleur pourpre de steven
spielberg
c'est un spielberg sans effets spéciaux
sans poudre aux yeux sans extraterrestes
sans camion fou et sans monstre sous
marins c'est une histoire presque
conventionnelle celle d'une famille de
noirs américains dans le sud des états
unis
c'est en tout cas la preuve que
spielberg a choisi le camp des adultes
après avoir longtemps séjourné dans la
cour des enfants
un film superbe qui n'a pourtant pas
suffi à dépeupler la croisette il est
vrai qu'ici on vit à l'heure du cinéma
vu par les télévisions
quelque chose dans le genre de regarder
si l'on m'a bien reconnu mais c'est
aussi parfois l'occasion d'une image
cocasse comme cette voiture qui marchent
à l'eau
ça c'est donc le festival côté mer côté
cavs il ya le festival du business et
des contrats on discute on négocie que
l'on parle déjà de cannes 1987
et puis il ya le cinéma des créateurs
avec la projection de main de l'otello
de verdi mise en scène par zeffirelli
c'est vers sa chambre que nous mêmes
cette musique
une question pour franco zeffirelli
il emporte du film ou de l'opéra
si les mains doivent être les plus
l'objet principal de cette opération
ce qui veut dire que vous n'êtes pas
hésité à couper dans la musique a le
talent et on voudrait couper tout de
même parce que le père est trop longue
des f 35
il y à une quantité de matériel musical
qu'est très bien ne sais quelle forme et
pas seulement cette semaine au théâtre
mais sur un état acceptable pour les
versions ces motos profitent de cet
opéra ces grands problèmes survenus
quand j'ai commencé à tourner chaque
scène
on peut dire qu'il est avec lui ces
exceptions avec besoin d'être touchés
musicalement pas ce que voulaient les
temps des cinémas de rythme
cinématographique n'est pas ce qui
correspondait pas au rythme de la
musique poule pour les plateaux
m
tél
la blanche je ne la géologie et tout ça
c'était ma femme est dans le monde ou
demander un garçon d'une fille de huit
ans qu'elle vous avez déjà un taux
jamais entendu l'hôtel vous diront qu'il
avait eue savent quel hôtel hôtel de ces
l'état mais la géorgie mais en plus ce
thé last comme j'avais indiqué et c'est
extraordinaire moment raciale d'un grand
noir avec une belle blanche meubles de
les siennes
et la référence météo ici c'est de
rambouillet que d'honneur que donnait
aux à vue sur le reportage de bernard à
cannes il y avait du soleil et bien je
pense que demain sur le même reportage
il y en aura un peu moins on assiste une
petite rechute du mauvais temps c'est
comme ça qu'on fasse une toute petit
rocher
on regarde tout de suite la carte du
temps prévu pour demain avec des nuages
presque partout des menaces et des
éclaircies temps nuageux le matin sur la
moitié nord avec des passages de ciel
couvert quelques puits puis des
éclaircies dans l'après midi ciel
orageux l'après midi sur tout l'est du
pays et sur les pyrénées enfin sur
l'extrême sud est c'est à dire sur
cannes et sur l'accord scellant ce matin
et puis un petit peu plus nuageux
l'après-midi chute aussi du côté des
températures et où les nuages harry le
sont par nature baisse le 13 degrés à
cerveau jusqu'à 18 degrés à paris sur la
moitié nord et de 17° à limoges jusqu'à
24 degrés à ajaccio sur la moitié sud
demain il fera 17 degrés à bruxelles il
21° à rome on termine rapidement avec
notre agent d'al ce demain jeudi 15 mai
le soleil se lèvera à 6 heures qu on se
couchera à 21h20 à 3 minutes de soleil
en plus nous fêterons les denise alors
bonne fête de l'eau je vous rappelle que
monsieur françois léotard a annoncé à
l'assemblée nationale la privatisation
immédiate de tf1 et puis que monsieur
philippe seguin au cours du conseil des
ministres est annoncée à déposer son
projet de loi de suppression de
l'autorisation administrative préalable
de licenciement
monsieur mitterrand le président de la
république a exprimé sa désapprobation
et ses fortes réserves sur ce projet de
monsieur seguin le dernier journal de la
rédaction d'antenne 2 ce sera après le
grand échiquier de jacques chancel en
direct de cannes et philippe harrouard
recevra françois loncle du parti
socialiste et bertrand cousin du rpr
pour parler de l'audiovisuel et puis
demain monsieur alain madelin sera
l'invité de télématin à demain 20h
bonsoir merci